during a vaginal childbirth the first
stage of labor lasts about 12 to 19
hours and starts when your baby settles
lower into your pelvis in response your
cervix begins to efface or become
thinner and dilate or widen during this
time you may feel strong regular
contractions occurring every five to
twenty minutes and lower back pain and
cramping that doesn't go away you may
see a brownish or reddish mucous
discharge which could be the mucous plug
at the opening of your cervix falling
out your water may break which can
either be a large gush of fluid or a
continuous trickle if you experience any
of these symptoms contact your doctor or
Midwife to see if you should go to the
hospital at the beginning of stage two
of labor which can last from a few
minutes to three hours your cervix is
fully dilated to 10 centimeters and your
baby's head has moved beyond the
cervical opening into your birth canal
during this stage you will begin to push
your baby out you may instinctively push
when you feel the urge or you may need
coaching from your doctor midwife or
labor nurse as to when to push and when
to rest in a normal delivery your baby's
head will rotate to face your back
during active labor your uterus is
divided into an active segment that
contracts pushing the baby downward and
a flexible passive segment that remains
relaxed stretching to provide more room
for the baby to pass through in some
cases when the top of your baby's head
appears or crowns
your doctor may make a small cut called
an episiotomy to enlarge the vaginal
opening then you will continue pushing
your baby out
as your baby's head passes through the
birth canal it molds into an elongated
shape an elongated head shape will
resolve itself within a few days as the
skull bones shift back into place after
your baby's head exits the birth canal
his or her head and shoulders will
rotate to help the shoulders pass
through the birth canal your baby's
shoulders are delivered one after the
other in order to fit through your
pelvis
once the shoulders emerge the rest of
your baby slides out easily
after your baby is born his or her
umbilical cord will be cut in stage 3 of
labor which may last five to 30 minutes
mild contractions will help push the
placenta out of the uterus during this
stage you and your baby may begin
bonding through skin-to-skin contact and
breastfeeding